لا شيء ينافس السمكه المسكوفك وجبه غذاء
مفضله ورخيصه لدى العراقيين
لكن هذا الحاله بالنسبه لكثيرين بدا يتغير
مؤخرا مع تراجع كميه الاسماك المعروضه في
الاسواق وارتفاع الاسعار
8000 دينار الله يقبل محمد من تراب
ما عندي من يجي 15 دينار يشتري كلمه ب 30
دينار
على نهر دجله يكتمل المشهد علي وصاحبه
اللذان ينتهينان صيد السمك منذ عقود
يستعداني ليوم صيد جديد
يرمي عليه شباكه لعلها تعود اليه بصيد
وفير كما كان يحدث قبل سنوات
لكن بعد انتظار يلمني شباكه وهي خاويه
يقول ان قله منسوب المياه القادمه الى
العراق من دول المنبع ليست السبب الوحيد
لهذا الحال
وعدنا يعني قلت منسوب المهاء العفو والصيد
الجائر
وبالسم والكهرباء
يقول مختصون ان الثروه السمكيه تشكلت في
ما مضار كيزه مهمه في الاقتصاد العراقي
ويطالبون بتفعيل الاتفاقيات التي تحمي هذه
الثروه والصيادين نحتاج الى تفعيل
القوانين حمايه البيئه حمايه الصيادين هذا
ايضا الان الهجوم العشوائي في موسم
التكاثر العمليات الصيد لا توجد رقابه لا
توجد قواني الراجعه هذا من الداخل نحتاجه
الى تفعيل الاتفاقيات الدوليه لحمايه
الدوليه
باطلاقه حصص العراق المائيه
تظهر ارقام وزاره الزراعه ان وفره الامطار
وزياده كميات المياه المتدفقه من دول
الجوار في عام 2020 وصلت البلاد الى مستوى
الاكتفاء الذاتي من الثروه السمكيه
لكنها تراجعت في العامين الماضيين الى
النصف بسبب تراجع مستوى المياه
قبل عقد من الزمان اما الان فلم يبقى منها
سواء ثلاثه فقط صوره تعكس الحاله الذي وصل
اليه قطاعا يمكن ان يشكل ركنا مهما في
الامن الغذائيه العراقي لو احسنت ادارته
بحسب القائمين عليه
وليد ابراهيم الجزيره بغداد